im becken leute und die anwender länder
2019 wir sind gespannt
oft machen soll ich mir keinen kopf
machen software.de
hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne
und willkommen zu einem neuen anfang an
nicht mich ist es schon das zehnte ich
hoffe nicht dass ich schon das zehnte
ist aber heute haben wir den
wunderschönen einzigartigen amazon
beauty adventskalender deswegen auch
ungeschminkt und so aus als ob ich
gerade aus dem bett aufgestanden wäre
weil ich lese gerade aus dem bett
aufgestanden
ich habe richtig bock in den
adventskalender auszupacken ich kann
mich nicht so ganz erinnern ich glaube
letztes mal war dann kommt oder ich
hatte viele produkte die ich danach noch
lange benutzt hat und falls es auf
schminke gibt oder irgendwas fürs
gesicht können wir uns auch unsere
welchen meter drauf machen dann aber
schön dass uns alle wieder hier
zusammengefunden haben
ich habe diesen adventskalender vor
langer zeit gestellt sehr sehr langer
zeit der ist ausverkauf der so beliebten
der gekostet am 17 oktober bestellen
viereinhalb von fünf sternen das heißt
er muss echt sein
lasst uns den auspacken moharos glaub
ich hab vor zwei jahren eröffnet wenn es
keinen ausgepackt und da war dieser
adventskalender boom noch nicht so krass
mit jedem jahr kommen mehr firmen mit
adventskalender um die ecke zb erp
hammer adventskalender dieses jahr
wirklich du hast dich selbst übertroffen
was soll das ich habe auch irgendwo
gesehen dass sie gesagt haben dass sie
mich eingeladen haben also so ein
statement ich weiß aber nicht wo sie
mich eingeladen haben gefühlt vielleicht
habe ich auch übersehen aber einladung
kam es jetzt noch nicht vielleicht sie
auch im spam-ordner gelandet weil er
immer so viele newsletter ausschickt
dass mein e mail fach einfach denkt
keine keine werbung mehr hier aber ich
habe keine bekommen aber gut daran
sollte aber nicht gehen wir machen jetzt
türchen nummer eins auf und ich werde
mir die cremes heute ins gesicht
schmieren und alles ausprobieren
advent advent nur noch 23 tage bis
weihnachten triggert mich irgendwie
gerade dass ich das nicht rein
advent advent nur noch 23 tage bis
weihnachten
na siehste deswegen ist der ausverkauf
weil ihr hammer produkt mit grinsen
meyrin türchen nummer eins ist die
organic indischen von dem ihres lip balm
viel und gerne kindischen ich habe
gehört dass lipcare gar nicht so gut
sein soll und der beste tipp von mir ist
wenn ihr trockene lippen habt bedeutet
dass meistens dass ihr zu wenig wasser
trinken klingt sehr einfach es wird auch
also organic öle und bio sheabutter das
ist super glutenfrei domain der richter
noch wie weihnachten oder dass das wird
dieses jahr mein favourit hammer so muss
der wähler weiter machen sich ende mai
in 22 tagen ist weihnachten das ist
nicht einmal daran erinnert ja das ist
so eine straffende intensiv maske das
ding ist mit diesen masken ist so meine
guilty pleasure
ich liebe schied masken aber es tut
jedes mal wieso eine zu benutzen weil es
dann doch so viel
öl produziert das ist das was man aber
aufgeben muss für den planeten wenn ihr
heute noch nicht angekommen seid und
sagt hey aber ich kann nicht auf alles
achten verstehen aber man muss sich
bewusst sein dass so was ja viel müll
produziert ok türchen nummer drei hat
google app von greenpeace enthält
schmieden sprüh maske ohne ausspülen mit
duft von grünem tee für die haken 0
so wartet richtiger juli blogger wow das
sprüht creme raus an die schönen weg in
die haare machen griechenlands macht
wohnhaus spiel zum sprühen werde ich auf
jeden fall ausprobieren ich bin gespannt
fliegt auf jeden fall sehr gut
fachleute zu oft die nummer vier
ich finde es so süß dass wir immer steht
nur noch 20 mal schlafen jetzt kind ist
auch immer gesehen aber das kenne ich
schon vom letzten jahr glaube es ist
diese balance i pansy gericht auch
richtig gut grapefruit lief ja das ist
eine super schöner zweifel kann ich kann
sie empfehlen nicht wirklich jetzt oder
hand und body wash hat seine probleme
sind aber ich glaub das zeug ist
existiert natürlich ende machen nix
wimperntusche worth the hype
ich hab dich schon mal von nyx manchmal
sachen geschenkt wow das ist das hier
auch richtig julia titel drin sind im
preis der super hammer klasse meine
wimpern durch das nämlich gerade alle
geworden hab ich ganz nah die shopping
queen wimperntusche benutzer über diesen
auch weil alle weil die so klein war
ja man sieht wahrscheinlich gar keinen
unterschied oder ob nicht ein bisschen
küche und nikolaus was kriegen wir an
nikolaus überlegen was ich an nikolaus
machen möchte ich möchte irgendwann
special machens und essen oder so
organisieren konnte ich dachte schon
dass da was richtig krass ist drin ist
detailliert mit sonic facial klinsi was
die haben so ein foto oder reingemacht
ich meine das ist eine kleine größe aber
diese fotos sind der hammer die
vibrieren unsere warm und dann gibt es
ja so gesichts machten dazu die ich auch
habe viel an
wir sind offen lux ist raus du musst
halt die maske drauf und dann vibriert
du dass du in deiner haut rein und das
ist halt gesagt nicht das ist ein weg
ding ist
bitte nicht bitte bis nein man kann
es ist nicht wie georgia wellness ist
für 100 plus user kannst du das halt
schön einmassieren ja
weil meine arme verlosung habe das
damals ja auch dann gecheckt dass so
sachen die man nicht neu aufladen kann
halt einfach so elektronik für den müll
gemacht wird und das finde ich auch ganz
ganz schlimm mittlerweile ich werde das
jetzt natürlich benutzen aber schaut
dass ihr auf jeden fall solche sachen
nicht absichtlich kauft die nur für plus
100 mal gemacht sind darauf gibt ein
großes teil was man aufladen kann
aber das kostet auch extrem viel ok
türchen nummer 7 wo elisabeth also meine
fingernägel sehen vielleicht ein
bisschen schmutzig aus vielleicht sind
sie ist ganz bisschen aber meine finger
gesehen schmutzig aus weil ich viel
gemalt hat in letzter zeit und auf
meinen fingernägeln so ganz viele reste
habt von farbe und so deswegen sieht das
ein bisschen nass sie auch so in new
york erinnert kapseln 1 racing niveau
anti falten serum inso kapseln richtigen
moment schnell den körper dann hat man
so sehr um aber genutzt man ist aber
auch er seine papiere größe aber nicht
ich weiß wie toll sich in nummer ab
heute ist der zweite advent nur noch 16
wallschlag feind shiny lipstick und
lipliner die plastikverpackung es
absolut unnötig gewesen das schönste nix
das muss nicht sein
wie das amazon team das braucht man
nicht das muss nicht dazu kommen die
packung wird es überleben in diesem aber
was für eine farbe soll das sein das ist
mal pink oder was sagt ihr das ist mal
ein richtiges ping und elena ist auch
ein richtiges pink feind kennt ihr die
schlau eint ist die die amazon hausmarke
okay weil es die amazon hausmarke das
komm wir probieren es aus ich mache mir
jetzt einfach übertrieben pinke lippen
aber das ist ja in beauty channels ich
bin mega überrascht gerade ich finde das
produkt richtig gut also hermann alle
kleider da kann sich sehen lassen der
lässt sich gut auf tragen und ist nicht
zu weich was es nicht mehr an geld
kommen die pinke lippen
er ist ein bisschen her
jetzt will ich außen sondern ein nein
gibt com als ob das eine farbe ist die
so viele leute tragen
ich finde es produkt nicht schlecht als
es fällt auf jeden fall nicht durch aber
die farbe es ist halt ein lob muss man
irgendwie st
vielleicht sollte man einfach was neues
ausprobieren nicht immer nur in seiner
komfortzone in seiner komfortzone
türchen nummer neuen bio report
tiefenreinigung stripes die dinkel auf
ich doch einfach gar nicht mehr solche
stripes haben bei mir nie funktioniert
let's face it schmutz und teig
verursachen mitesser die jederzeit
auftreten können dagegen muss zu
erinnern wird mit sein okay auch hier
wieder dazu unsere produkte das ist halt
das sage ich euch
ich finde aber die ganze beauty
industrie ist nicht gerade
umweltfreundlich was ich habe jetzt
irgendwie wieder so ein schwarzen
erwartet das ja meistens um die
aktivkohle oder so okay da fühlen wir
bauen sind also so wie ich das jetzt
beurteilen kann
ich habe sehr viel verstopfte poren ein
sehr viele mit es nicht diese schwarzen
und ich sage so ist auf jeden fall
blockieren es ist halt ein lob muss man
irgendwie sagen die nummer 10 ist gute
eine trockenshampoo blaue flasche und
flirty problem ist nur bei hellen habe
ich mir das gefühl dass man eine
ja ich habe so dunkle haare da hat ein
helles trockenshampoo nicht viele chance
sicherheit auch das habe ich schon grau
werden deswegen schreiben sie genug
entfernung aber ich lieb' trockenshampoo
weil es immer schönes volumen jahre mal
vor allem wenn man so ganz feines haar
hat uns jeden tag irgendwie fertig wird
war zu dünn ist ein bisschen trocken
schaffen ansatz ein bisschen
durchschütteln und man hat wieder
volumen mussten jeden tag waschen putzen
nummer elf so viel zu entdecken ja ja ja
ja ja ich hab also strahlende haus mit
anti müdigkeit effekt ab jetzt kommt
unter die augen es ist natürlich eine
augen machen
es wäre so nicht witzig wenn ich jetzt
hier so eine allergische reaktion auf
den screen habe endlich kann ich mir was
unter die auch mir immer wenn ich mich
ein creme habe ich nichts für die auch
und dann fühlen sich meine augen dann
male ich sehe zehn jahre jünger aus
bezüglich alkohol weltkrieges hat schon
sofort wow effekt findet ihr nicht auch
wir sind in der hälfte angekommen
türchen nummer 12 und wir kriegen wieder
eine gesichtsmaske von coco star
die gab es letztes jahr oder vor letztes
jahr schon das sind halt kleinemas
schied die aussehen wie kursen oder
zitronen und dann kannst du dir so
verteilt auflegen ist auch ganz gut aber
wie gesagt masken machen sehr viel müll
es ist ein guilty pleasure kann man ja
nicht
für jene man bereits sehen ok jahres
zehn minuten ich noch nie was von mir
es könnte eine handcreme sein plan passt
die freude am guten geschmack die
cremige zahnpasta bietet ein intensives
geschmackserlebnis und hilft das
zahnbelag 10 wird für weiße zähne und
entspannt lächelt der exotisch süße zimt
verbindet sich mit der kraft von wenn
sie zu einem überraschend frischen aroma
eine zahnpasta die nach zimt schmeckt
lecker wir tun habe jetzt ein
strahlendes lächeln sie schmeckt schon
extrem gut
ich habe nur ein bisschen was im hals
gekriegt und dann dachte ich dass ich
dagegen allergisch bin und ich habe mal
gegen irgendwas ehrlich zu sein und dann
spielt man hals ein und ich habe
niemanden den ich anrufen können ja geil
was es nicht alles gibt nicht so wir
können unsere nasen maske abziehen
und ich meine nase dafür richtig
gewaschen dass ich nicht so üblich ist
werde ich glaube ich richtig gut gewesen
das heißt so richtig die haut mit super
türchen nummer 14
rachel magic touch body cream schon
meine macht den charity portal geht der
erlös an eine gute genauer yamashita
tours eincremen oder durch das hammer
manche lachen bringen so cool ich dich
nicht süß hat wie babypuppe nicht
weniger aber irgendwie solchem eine
dieser sachen nummer 15 ist ein
riesenpaket gab es etwa eine kooperation
mit rachel es gibt schon das zweite
produkt sensation vgh
du schaust geil der duft ist wirklich
hammer nummer 16 der tabelle und
niewerth zusammen beiersdorf und wo es
jeder polizist dorf
beides wird von beiersdorf produziert
ich benutze aber gar kein appell mehr
weil alle immer sagen glaubt wer macht
die lippen noch schlimmer und nie wer
finde ich auch nicht so gut so eine
kleine krems mal praktischen habe ich
bin kein fan von den beiden produkten 17
es ist aber schon krass
das ist schon cool adventskalender also
wenn ich mir vorstellen würde
jeden tag so ein richtiges produkte mir
zum entdecken auszupacken schon cool
gliss kur harry per booster brauchen
ihre haare einen extra metern bot ja
manchmal schon dann macht man davon so
zwei tropfen eine spülung das ist ja das
habe ich noch nie gesehen 18 nur noch
sechs tage bis weihnachten
dezember wird so schnell umgehen ich
weiß es jetzt schon und man wird an
weihnachten da sitzen und sagen wo ist
dieses jahr schon wieder hinein
aha-effekt tonics kind manager
gm manager die ersten manager bietet
eine effektiv wirksame formulierung mit
frucht säure und einem niedrigen ph-wert
türchen nummer 19
wir können auch die produkte hier so
display also nummer 19 in willi baur
willst von den irgendwie symbolbild kann
man auch nie genug haben oder wo mit
glitzer mit schulze habe ich noch nicht
oder rom ja dass so ein leichter gleich
metallischer look für die christmas zeit
total natürlich die nummer 20 habe jetzt
begeistert mich die produktion gerade
mit neuester rising anti aging sun
protection braucht man es doch im winter
brauchen als auch ne leute im winter
müsst ihr auch eure sun protection
machen
türchen nummer eins extensions steyn
mascara bis zu drei tage halt ok erstmal
wir haben das cover tragen
also das muss jetzt eine richtig gute
mascara sein
also wenn ihr diese mascara kennt
schreibt man gerne in die kommentare ob
ihr wisst ob sie wirkt das würde mich
wirklich interessieren
aber jetzt will kommt mir meine seht ihr
den unterschied und in beiden hier ist
braucht da nicht ja okay ich weiß nicht
was sie macht ich hoffe die kriegt man
nicht allzu schwer wieder runter ist
immer noch nicht zu vergleichen mit
meinen wimpern extensions ich mir mal
drauf klebt aber auf jeden fall schon
mal was her
tschechien 22 heute ist der vierte
advent noch zweimal schlafen
wenn die hellen creams die in krems kann
ein mensch haben aber okay das habe ich
meine harry potter handys und die mit
die sandforce am eingang zum travelex
chiemsee von duft und duftstoffe soap
keeping paris und stockholm
die sind bestimmt gut die sofi soap ihn
ja dürfen gut an cremes und da ganz
ehrlich sie sind made in korea
ja ich hab sie jetzt sind aus korea
ich sehe gerade nämlich so diese
koreanische stiften
die schrift erkenne ich doch julian 23
weil das leben geht uns neben dem lidl
mit toni areal noch eine schippe sdi ist
aus kohle hin koreanische beautyprodukte
leute es wehrt euch im dezember mal
meine biotin zeigen koreanische produkte
sind einfach ist beste die haben
irgendwie oft missverstanden
so ist weihnachten der 24 dezember
und was bekommen wir von amazon beauty
was glaubt amazon was wir an weihnachten
brauchen
frohe weihnachten 2009 10 dankeschön
amazon das ist noch nicht so weit aber
ich freue mich trotzdem ja ich weiß es
ist wahrscheinlich mega kreis mini
einsatz maxi wirkung von babor das ist
also super teure produkte das sind so
ampullen jetzt ist ja anscheinend so ein
mega luxus ich kann mich darüber gerade
aber nicht so richtig freuen weil ich
nicht so diese am typ bin kommt einfach
mal cool
ich möchte mir die perfekte oder die
sofortige werte für einen sofort effekt
bei falten und linien leute wir wollen
einen support gar nicht dass hier so
abziehen ja ich glaube das ist jetzt in
brechen werden das macht mir so angst
dass man so glasbrechen muss für beide
wissen was ich meine
wir werden jetzt sofort geliftet
präsident obama gar nicht so schlimm
jetzt ist es geköpft lüttich - das ist
einfach ins gesicht oder dieses serum
zeug also so sehe ich feuer aus das ist
richtige so jetzt verteile ich das wiki
macht man davon scheint wahrscheinlich
viel zu jung es riecht sehr gut
hoffentlich werde jetzt nicht motor
diesen sofortigen effekt haben wenn sie
mir versprechen wahr machen das mache
die schön hier
richtig ein bisschen scheiße oh ja er
hat das zeug ist richtig teuer deswegen
ist auch an weihnachten drin
ich fühle mich jetzt gar nicht gesagt
nicht so bestraft wenn jetzt aber auch
noch nicht so alt dass man ist sofort
irgendwie so krass aber wenn ich jetzt
ein fan von dass es gab kein fans und
sogar scheiße werden
oh mein gott fühlt sich mégane ich finde
mein hautbild sieht jetzt sehr sehr
strahlend und das was ich meine sind
jetzt so fresh aus also ich denke immer
leute die diese produkte verwenden
schwören auch darauf ja ich finde meine
haut sieht fantastisch aus danach ich
habe das gefühl die hatten richtig
gesunden glanz ich immer diese empfohlen
wird erstmal bestehe hier ist über was
sollen wir sagen kommt ganz ehrlich es
ist eine fantastische stadt rennkalender
denn viele tolle produkte drin man
kriegt sie sichtlich etwas für sein geld
und es wundert mich nicht dass der
ausgekauft ist dieses jahr werde ich den
auf jeden fall für meine
familienmitglieder bestellen das ist ein
krieg ist es natürlich toll an das
geländer
wer auf juli steht ich hoffe euch uns
gefallen
wir sehen uns im nächsten video wieder
hat noch einen adventskalender und ich
weiß nicht ob ich ihn sehe benutzen soll
oder ausparken sollte das werdet ihr
erfahren
das ist jetzt ein cliffhanger durch ab
dezember leute wird so gewesen dass es
kommt jetzt viel auf euch zu und
besonders viel auf mich zu denn ja
dezember dezember will heftig
[Musik]
aber blieb das spiel zunächst